KENNEDY, DANA PERINO,
JUAN WILLIAMS, AND GREG GUTFELD.
IT’S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE"."
IT LOOKS LIKE IT COULD BE GAME
OVER FOR THE DEMOCRATS
IMPEACHMENT SPECTACLE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS BEEN
DECLARING VICTORY ON TWITTER AND
REPUBLICANS HAVE BEEN SIGNALING
THAT THEY COULD VOTE TO ACQUIT
THE PRESIDENT AS EARLY AS
TOMORROW.
HERE ARE SOME HIGHLIGHTS FROM
THE TRIAL TODAY.
SPEAK AT THIS POINTS TO THE
EXACT PROBLEM TAKING PLACE HERE,
THAT IS MY COLLEAGUE HAS SAID TH
IS REALLY TAKING THE VOTE AWAY
FROM THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
SPEAK ABOUT WHAT WE HAVE SEEN
OVER THE LAST COUPLE DAYS IS A
DESCENT INTO CONSTITUTIONAL
MADNESS.
SPEAK OF THE PRESIDENT, BY HIS
ACCOUNT, NEVER ONCE ASKED HIS SO
LEAVE THE BOARD.
INSTEAD, HE STARTED
INVESTIGATING THE PROSECUTOR WHO
WAS GOING AFTER BURISMA AND HIS
CORRUPT OLIGARCH.
>> Jesse: THE REASONING
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS READY TO
DECLARE VICTORY ARE BECAUSE OF
TWO VIDEOS SERVICING FROM
JOHN BOLTON AND ADAM SCHIFF.
>> I WILL BE MEETING WITH
PRESIDENT ZELENSKY.
HE AND PRESIDENT TRUMP HAVE
ALREADY MET TWICE PIER THE
PRESIDENT CALLED TO CONGRATULATE
PRESIDENT ZELENSKY ON HIS
ELECTION AND HIS SUCCESS IN
THE PARLIAMENTARY ELECTION.
THEY WERE VERY WARM, CORDIAL
CALLS.
THERE WERE HOPING THEY WOULD BE
ABLE TO MEET IN WARSAW.
>> PARTICULARLY GIVEN THE
HISTORY WHERE WE HAD THE
POLITICIZATION OF INTELLIGENCE
OVER WMD.
WHY WE WOULD PICK SOMEONE WHO,
THE VERY SAME ISSUE HAS BEEN
RAISED REPEATEDLY, AND THAT IS
JOHN BOLTON’S POLITICIZATION OF
CUBA AND OTHER ISSUES.
WHILE WE WOULD WANT SOMEONE WITH
THAT LACK OF CREDIBILITY I DON’T
UNDERSTAND.
>> Jesse: THAT HURTS, BUT
LET’S TAKE A LOOK AT IT FROM THE
WEEK.
DEMOCRATS WENT FIRST.
OBVIOUSLY LANDED SOME PUNCHES
AND THE REPUBLICAN DEFENSE CAME
IN SATURDAY, OBLITERATED THEM.
THEN YOU HAVE THIS LEAK ABOUT
BOLTON AND IT LOOKS LIKE THE
REPUBLICANS WERE GETTING A
LITTLE DEFENSIVE, AND I WAS THE
WHITE HOUSE TEAM HAS FINISHED
MAKING THEIR CASE, AND IT LOOKS
LIKE THERE WILL BE A VOTE ON
NO WITNESSES AND THE PRESIDENT
WILL BE ACQUITTED ON FRIDAY.
MAYBE SATURDAY MORNING.
WOW APPEARED A LOT TO DIGEST,
WILLIAMS.
>> Juan: I JUST FIND SO MUCH
OF THIS UPSETTING.
I START WITH, GAME OVER?
GAME OVER ON THE BASIS OF BOLTON
TAPES.
I THINK TO MYSELF, IF THAT’S THE
CASE, IF BOLTON IS EXONERATING
THE PRESIDENT, WHY WOULDN’T THE
PRESIDENT AND HIS TEAM WANT
BOLTON TO COME BEFORE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND TESTIFY?
BUT OF COURSE, WE KNOW THAT’S
NOT THE CASE.
HE DOESN’T WANT BOLTON ANYWHERE
NEAR THIS.
HE IN FACT IS PUTTING UP EVERY
ROADBLOCK TO STOP BOLTON FROM
TESTIFYING, AND HE CONTINUES TO
REFUSE TO RELEASE ANY MATERIAL.
THIS IS ALL SHOWMANSHIP, AND HE
IS TERRIFIC AT SHOWMANSHIP.
DONALD TRUMP CAN PUT ON A SHOW.
BUT IN TERMS OF PROTECTING THE
AMERICAN CONSTITUTION, IN TERMS
OF STOPPING US FROM BECOMING A
MONARCHY WITH A KING THAT
ANSWERS TO NO ONE, I JUST WONDER
WHAT IS GOING ON?
>> Jesse: I THINK THE
PRESIDENT HAS BEEN ANSWERING TO
A LOT OF PEOPLE SINCE HE WENT
AND OFFICE.
HE’S BEEN CHECKED EVERY SINGLE
DAY --
>> Juan: HE ANSWERS TO RUDY
GIULIANI RUDY GIULIANI.
>> Jesse: AND YOU KNOW THAT.
>> Juan: AND WHAT ABOUT RUDY
GIULIANI?
HE MAY KNOW SOMETHING.
>> Jesse: I CAN AFFORD MY OWN
LAWYER.
KENNEDY, WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT
THESE TAPES THAT HAVE SURFACED?
>> NONE OF THIS IS ALSO PRIZED.
THESE ARE POLITICIANS AND BY
NATURE THEY ARE GOING TO
CONTRADICT THEMSELVES.
ADAM SCHIFF WON IN 2000.
HE BEAT JIM ROGAN IN HIS
DISTRICT TO BECOME A CONGRESSMAN
BECAUSE OF HIS OUTRAGE OVER BILL
CLINTON’S IMPEACHMENT.
OBVIOUSLY, THE ARGUMENT HE MADE
HE IS NOW ARGUING AGAINST HIS
OWN LOGIC.
I UNDERSTAND POSITIONS CAN
EVOLVE, AND CERTAINLY IT’S BEEN
20 YEARS SINCE HE RAN FOR THAT
OFFICE AND HE’S BEEN STINKING UP
CONGRESS EVER SENSE, BUT
JOHN BOLTON CAN’T HAVE IT BOTH
WAYS.
HE CAN’T BE A PATRIOT AND A
COMPROMISE OR AT THE SAME TIME.
I ACTUALLY WOULDN’T MIND HEARING
FROM JOHN BOLTON.
I WANT TO HEAR HOW HE CAN SCORE
SOME OF THE SALACIOUS THINGS HE
HAS REPORTEDLY WRITTEN IN THIS
BOOK AND SAYING THE PRESIDENT
WAS WARM AND CORDIAL.
EITHER HE IS NOT A PATRIOT AND
HE WAS JUST DISSEMINATING
PROPAGANDA ON BEHALF OF THE
PRESIDENT BECAUSE HE’S TOTALLY
COMPROMISED HIMSELF OR SOMEWHERE
IN HERE HE’S LYING.
>> Jesse: RIGHT NOW, WE HAVE A
FEW MORE QUESTIONS AND THEN WHAT
DO WE DO TOMORROW?
A FEW MORE FINAL THOUGHTS AND
THEN WE WILL HOLD A VOTE.
>> Dana: THERE IS A TECHNICAL
THING, A GATEWAY VOTE, IF IT’S
CLEAR THAT’S GOING TO FAIL I
THINK THERE WILL BE A MOTION TO
HAVE THE ACQUITTAL VOTE AND
THERE’S SOME AMENDMENTS.
IT COULD BE A LONG NIGHT BUT I
DO BELIEVE MITCH McCONNELL HAS
STEERED REPUBLICANS IN A WAY
WHERE THEY WILL BE ABLE TO
FINISH THIS BY LATE FRIDAY
NIGHT, MAY BE EARLY MORNING.
IT COULD BE REALLY LATE NIGHT OR
AN EARLY MORNING DEPENDING ON
YOUR PERSPECTIVE.
I HAVE BEEN SURPRISED THAT
NOBODY HAS BROUGHT UP THE FACT
THAT IN SEPTEMBER, JUST A MONTH
AGO, THE INTERNATIONAL MONETARY
FUND, THEY FINALLY RELEASED
THEIR MONEY AND LOANS TO
UKRAINE.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE REASON THAT
THEY WERE HOLDING IT BACK LIKE
THEY WERE CONCERNED ABOUT IT, IT
WAS ALL ABOUT CORRUPTION.
THAT ISN’T A SURPRISE.
NOT A SURPRISE EITHER THAT
JOHN BOLTON, THE NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISOR WOULD GO ON
RADIO FREE EUROPE AND TALK ABOUT
CORRUPTION IN UKRAINE BECAUSE IT
WAS A WELL-KNOWN THING.
I WOULD ALSO POINT OUT THAT
SENATOR ALEXANDER FROM TENNESSEE
WAS CONSIDERED SOMEBODY WHO HAS
THIS GREAT REPUTATION AND HE
DOESN’T WANT TO SULLY THAT AND
HE’S RETIRING AT THE END OF THIS
YEAR, SO MAYBE THE DEMOCRATS
THOUGHT HE WOULD VOTE FOR
IMPEACHMENT.
OVER THE PAST TWO DAYS UNLESS I
HAVE MISSED SOMETHING IN THE
LAST COUPLE MINUTES, HE HASN’T
ASKED A SINGLE QUESTION WHICH
MAKES ME THINK HE HAS ALL THE
INFORMATION HE NEEDS AND THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE FAILED TO FORCE A
VOTE ON WITNESSES.
AND THAT IS A CONTRAST WITH WHAT
THE MEDIA SAYS.
THE MEDIA ALWAYS SAYS
REPUBLICANS DON’T HAVE ENOUGH
VOTES TO BLOCK WITNESSES.
IT’S ACTUALLY THAT THE DEMOCRATS
HAVEN’T BEEN ABLE TO PROVE THEIR
CASE BEYOND A REASONABLE DOUBT
AND FORCE A VOTE.
>> Kennedy: VERY QUICKLY TO
ADD TO THAT, THAT FRUSTRATED
SUSAN COLLINS.
SHE IS ONE OF THE PEOPLE WE’VE
BEEN LOOKING TO --
>> Jesse: THE MEDIA ALWAYS
TRIES TO BOX REPUBLICANS AND
WITH THEIR NARRATIVE.
SPEAKING OF THE MEDIA, THIS IS
JOE LOCKHART SAYING SOME REALLY
EXPLOSIVE STUFF ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT.
>> WHAT I THOUGHT WHEN I WAS
WATCNG IT IS THIS IS
UN-AMERICAN.
THIS IS WHAT YOU HEAR FROM
STALIN, WHAT YOU HEAR FROM
MUSSOLINI, FROM AUTHORITARIANS,
FROM HITLER.
ALL THE AUTHORITARIANS WHO
RATIONALIZED, IN SOME CASES,,
BASED ON WHAT WAS IN THE
PUBLIC INTEREST.
>> Jesse: ALAN DERSHOWITZ
BEING VERY EFFECTIVE IN THE
MEDIA’S GOING AFTER HIM BIG
TIME.
>> Greg: I’M GOING TO MISS
THIS.
I HOPE THEY DON’T VOTE ON THIS
TOMORROW BECAUSE I’M STARTING TO
LIKE THIS A LOT.
>> Jesse: KNOW YOU ARE NOT.
>> Greg: WITH THE MEDIA IS
DOING IS INTENTIONALLY
MISREPRESENTING WHAT
ALAN DERSHOWITZ SAID.
HE SAID YOU CAN’T BE IMPEACHED
FOR DOING SOMETHING IN THE
NATIONAL INTEREST IF IT ALSO
HELPS YOUR REELECTION BECAUSE
EVERYTHING YOU DO THAT IS GOOD
HELPS YOU IN A REELECTION.
IMPEACHMENT ABOUT THIS, WHICH IS
ABOUT INVESTIGATING CORRUPTION
IN THE UKRAINE, YOU COULD JUST
AS EASILY IMPEACH HIM OR
INTRODUCE A MIDDLE EAST PEACE
PLAN OR A TRADE DEAL, BECAUSE
THAT ALSO HELPS HIS PERSONAL
INTERESTS.
>> Juan: I ALWAYS LISTEN TO
YOU, BUT --
>> Greg: KEEP LISTENING!
YOU’VE BEEN TALKING ALL DAY!
THAT IS WHY BOLTON’S BOMBSHELL
ACTUALLY HELPED TRUMP BECAUSE IT
HELPS THE IDEA THAT TRUMP’S
INTEREST WASN’T CORRUPTION.
IF A SPACE ALIEN CAME DOWN AND
SAID, I SEE TWO SIDES.
ONE SIDE SAYS IMPEACH, THE OTHER
SIDE SAYS QUIT.
WHAT IS THE DIFFERENCE?
ONE HAS BEEN SAYING IMPEACHMENT
FOR THREE SOLID YEARS.
THAT IS THE DIFFERENCE.
THAT EXPLAINS THE EMOTION, THE
HYPERBOLE, BECAUSE THEY PUT
YEARS INTO THIS.
THIS IS A SUNK COST THAT THEY
CAN’T LET GO.
I KNOW WHAT YOU’RE GOING TO SAY
SOME GOING TO PREEMPT YOU.
>> Juan: THANK YOU.
>> Greg: THE REASON THESE TWO
SIDES MIRROR EACH OTHER IS
BECAUSE IT REALLY IS ABOUT THE
POWER OF CONGRESS VERSUS THE
POWER OF THE PRESIDENT.
DERSHOWITZ SAID IF YOU CAN
IMPEACH OVER OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE, WHICH IS VAGUE, THAT
GIVES THE CONGRESS TOO MUCH
POWER.
EVERY CONGRESS NOW CAN IMPEACH
THE PRESIDENT AT A WHIM AND THE
PRESIDENT BECOMES A PUPPET.
THE OTHER SIDE SAYS, IF YOU
DON’T IMPEACH HIM, TRUMP IS A
TYRANT AND A KING.
YOU SEE HOW THE ARGUMENT IS
EXACTLY EQUAL.
THE ONLY DIFFERENCE IS ONE HAS
BEEN DOING IT FOR THREE DAMN
YEARS.
>> Jesse: GREG GUTFELD DID NOT
CARE ABOUT IMPEACHMENT FOR
MONTHS AND MONTHS.
>> Greg: I’VE BEEN TRYING.
>> Juan: TO THE AUDIENCE, TO
BE VERY CLEAR, THIS IS NOT ABOUT
CORRUPTION IN THE UKRAINE.
THIS IS ABOUT TRUMP SEEKING DIRT
ON JOE BIDEN!
>> Greg: YOU JUST VALIDATED MY
POINT.
>> Juan: YOU KNOW, THAT IS THE
YOU SAID IT IS ABOUT CORRUPTION.
IT IS NOT ABOUT CORRUPTION.
IT IS ABOUT HIM TRYING TO HELP
HIMSELF --
>> Greg: YOU’RE READING HIS
MIND, YOU’RE READING HIS MIND.
>> Kennedy: YOU WANTED TRUMP’S
TAX RETURN, AND YOU ASKED A LOT
OF DETAILS BECAUSE HE’S RUNNING
FOR PRESIDENT, WHY ISN’T IT OKAY
TO ASK QUESTIONS ABOUT JOE BIDEN
WHEN HE WAS VICE PRESIDENT?
WHY IS IT OKAY NOT HAVE THE SAME
LINE OF INQUIRY?
>> Juan: BECAUSE THIS IS
SOMETHING TRUMP’S LAWYERS ARE
SAYING, IT IS OKAY TO GET
INFORMATION FROM A FOREIGN
GOVERNMENT?
WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT?
THAT IS EXACTLY IN VIOLATION OF
CAMPAIGN FINANCE FUNDS AND
LITERALLY NOBODY HAS SAID
JOE BIDEN HAS DONE ANYTHING
WRONG.
>> Jesse: EVERYBODY SAID IT!
>> Juan: NOBODY.
NOBODY.
>> Jesse: KNOW ALL THE
DEMOCRATS WHO ARE RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT AGAINST JOE BIDEN, I
WOULD NEVER --